pessoal o cobre e a vitamina C trabalham
juntos em muitos lugares do seu corpo
porém um dos mais importantes é na
construção de tecidos de colágeno a
vitamina C juntamente com ferro é
fundamental para uma das primeiras
etapas desse processo mas se você
estiver tomando muito ácido ascó
vitamina C sem saber como está o seu
cobre no organismo isso pode criar uma
deficiência de cobre aliás pessoal muita
atenção aqui tomar muito zinco também
pode levar a uma deficiência relativa de
cobre já que o zinco compete com ele com
cobre na absorção pelo corpo
recentemente Muitas pessoas têm tomado
suplementos de zinco em excesso toma
cuidado com isso e provavelmente não tem
combinado essa suplementação em alguns
casos é necessário juntar o cobre isso
pode desequilibrar as proporções de
zinco e cobre no organismo e levar uma
deficiência importante do cobre